es gibt mittlerweile ja auch ein
versteck der heißt wir wollen masken
pflicht der es gibt eine in der
gesellschaft einen willen bei vielen gar
nicht so wenigen auf keinen fall aus
dieser pandemie irgendwie raus zu
gleiten
herr montgomery der ärztefunktionär ist
auch so ein fall und zwar das ist das
erstaunliche relativ unabhängig von der
lage der man sich befindet wie die lage
im herbst und winter sein wird kann
niemand wissen es ist unbekanntes
gelände wie die zukunft im allgemeinen
von einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems und intensivstationen
keine rede sein kann ich damit ersparen
wir nicht widersprechen und dass die
inzidenz
infektionszahlen nicht mehr die
bedeutung haben die sie zu beginn der
pandemie hatten
[Musik]